[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
where is your god now
you know people i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct message it is
the last day of may it's may 31st 2022
we are live streaming on rumble youtube
and blaze tv i watched that little
compilation there about 10 times and i
have to say out of all of them it's the
peacock that gets me most not only
because peacock is a fun word to say but
we have a lot of peacocks here in
florida and i hear that sound constantly
and clyde is constantly chasing peacocks
and sometimes peacocks are chasing clyde
and that's a little insider info
as to what it is like to live here in
the free state of florida real quick
speaking of the free state of florida in
two days from now i will be in orlando
home of disney with governor ron
desantis i think there's like six or
eight tickets left the thing is pretty
much sold out about a thousand seats it
is going to be
as they tell me i say completely bananas
this is the culmination of the entire
don't burn this country tour and we are
going to orlando to disney country with
the governor and we're going to talk
about freedom and alligators and all
that good stuff if you want the last few
tickets you can go davereuben.com
events and i hope everybody had a good
memorial day weekend spent a little time
reflecting on uh the people
who uh who gave it all for this country
and uh who made our lives a lot easier
than their lives were i know i certainly
did i hope you ate some good food and i
hope you spend a little time with family
and friends as well and what we're going
to talk about today is actually the the
very thing
that the people who gave their lives for
this country uh we're trying to defend
that in many ways uh we seem to be just
sort of handing away right now the big
news over the last couple days was that
justin trudeau who i have not talked
about on this show for a couple weeks
now who is the prime minister of canada
who really is just a shell of a human
being i mean this guy is just an
absolute empty suit as jordan peterson
has eloquently said many times the guy
could not say something true if he tried
it's almost a gensake level
ability of lying that just the
inauthenticity is so extraordinary well
he has announced to canadian parliament
a massive massive move on guns and gun
rights in canada you won't be able to
buy them
transport them etc etc we'll play you
the video and so the theme today really
is that government tyranny in the west
is still
spreading if you thought all the covid
stuff
wasn't enough if you felt like
everything that we've seen over the last
couple weeks from the world economic
forum that there really is a virus that
was always much more dangerous than
covet and it is the virus that is within
all of us uh and that we just allow
freedom that people before us fought for
and died for uh we seemingly allow it to
just uh be taken away by people who will
gladly take it and take it uh so that
really will be the the theme for today
it's gonna be a jam packed show and real
quick guys i want to talk to you about
healthy cell have you ever wondered if
those vitamins you're taking every day
are actually working for you what if i
told you there's a new type of dietary
supplement one that'll absorb into your
body far better i want you to check out
healthy cell it's a new ingestible gel
that not only tastes great but has 165
percent more absorption than pills those
old-fashioned tablets capsules and
powders contain synthetic other
ingredients you ever wonder what they
are they're things like binding glues
fillers and coatings that can irritate
the lining of your stomach healthy cells
micro gel on the other hand suspends
soluble ultra absorbable nutrient
particles inside a natural
made
natural gel made of gut healthy
ingredients like soluble fiber citrus
pectin acasia gum and water it doesn't
contain artificial sweeteners flavorings
or colorings heck it's even non-gmo
gluten-free and vegetarian
i've been using the rem sleep packet you
just down one of these before bed you
will sleep connor you tried it did you
sleep well connor slept well phoenix
sleeping well michael sleeping right now
i'm telling you it's gonna work people
visit healthysell.com that's
healthycell.com
and use code ruben for 20
off your first order all right so let's
get right into it so justin trudeau i do
not like this man uh he is
representative to me of everything that
sort of lefty
liberal progressive politicians whether
they're in canada or america stand for
they sort of say things that kind of
make sense and then once you peer
peel through that very thin veneer you
find the worst sort of authoritarian
nonsense now we know this with trudeau
when it has come to vaccine mandates we
know this when it has come to lockdowns
everything that the trucker protest was
all about
in canada that we covered pretty
extensively that went on for weeks uh
this is a guy who wants power and he
does it while speaking very softly and
nicely and wearing colorful socks so
people seem to think he's a nice guy
because he has nice hair but he's also
often in blackface and he's pretty much
a racist and sort of the worst
sort of public person you could imagine
well here he is over the weekend talking
to canadian parliament about a new
canadian gun ban
we're introducing legislation to
implement a national freeze
on handgun ownership
what this means is that it will no
longer be possible to buy
sell
transfer or import handguns
anywhere in canada
in other words
we're capping the market for handguns
as a further part of this new
legislation we're also fighting gun
smuggling and trafficking by increasing
maximum criminal penalties and providing
more tools for law enforcement to
investigate firearm crimes
and will require the permanent
alteration of long gun magazines so they
can never
hold more than five rounds
okay so let's be clear about a couple
things here first off canada has no mass
gun violence problem now perhaps you can
argue that america does we can have a
discussion about that and that's going
to be an ongoing discussion obviously
going forward and it's been a discussion
for quite some time canada does not have
such a problem what's incredible about
that as he says that they are going to
ban buying selling transferring or
importing handguns
watching the masked now all those people
behind him they're all masked he's not
mass they're masked and you know it's
all theater they all take their masks
off the second the camera's not there
but watching them applaud
as the head of the government says hey
we are going to take away more of your
ability to defend yourselves and they
clap like seals throw me another fish
these people
are absolutely awful fear has just run
rampant in the worst sort of way in
canada and canadians have a limited
window as long as this guy is prime
minister to figure out how to right the
ship i i have great sympathy i know we
get a lot a lot of viewers in canada and
i know there are a lot of great freedom
fighters in canada like jordan peterson
and gadsat all of the truckers uh you
know maxine bernier there there are so
many but canada watching canada fall and
it has fallen in many ways do you know
that right now if you are unvaccinated
in canada you cannot leave canada by
train nor plane i think you can get in a
car and go but i'm not even sure about
that or you just have to evade the
authorities okay you cannot do that
you cannot leave the country that is
what a bad country does when a country
says hey you're not allowed to leave
that's kind of nazi germany kind of
stuff right it's a little different when
you say to people you can't leave rather
than you can't come in
but this is consistent with everything
that justin trudeau has done locking
down his people stopping protests spying
on people closing bank accounts etc etc
we've got many examples of it let's just
not forget only two months ago what was
trudeau saying about a group of people
who were protesting so that they could
open up the country so that they could
go to work go to school put food on the
table well listen to justin trudeau we
know
the way through this pandemic
is by getting
everyone vaccinated and the overwhelming
majority close to 90 percent of
canadians have done exactly that
the
small fringe minority
of people who are on their way to ottawa
or who are
holding unacceptable
views that they're expressing
do not represent
the views of canadians who have been
there for each other who know
that following the science
and stepping up to protect each other
is the best way to continue to ensure
our freedoms our rights our values as a
country
oh
vile human being those people right
those people those are the people who
have unacceptable views they're a fringe
minority what should we do to them
perhaps make sure they can't go to work
perhaps make sure that their kids can't
go to school
make sure that they're more dependent on
us can't defend themselves etcetera it
says it but et cetera et cetera but he
does it but he talks softly right he
sounds like a nice guy right he's a
really nice guys he takes away your guns
and your freedoms and all of those
things he's really really nice for doing
it as he demonizes the the people in
canada that are standing up for their
ability to live freely well it's not
just justin trudeau
here is you may remember this woman this
is finance minister christia
freeland and uh
her grandfather was a nazi by the way
nobody's guilty for their ancestors sins
but i'm just throwing it in there her
grandfather was a full-on nazi uh this
was her talking about the terror
financing act and what they're gonna do
to those scary fringe truckers
first we are broadening the scope of
canada's anti-money modern laundering
and terrorist financing rules
so that they cover crowd funding
platforms
and the payment service providers they
use these changes cover all forms of
transactions
including digital assets
such as crypto currencies
the illegal blockades have highlighted
the fact that crowdfunding platforms
and some of the payment service
providers they use
are not fully captured under the
proceeds of crime and terrorist
financing act
ah she would have made grandpa proud pop
would have been proud of her for what
she was doing to people who are just
fighting for freedom but it is marching
on in canada okay it is marching on and
these things are not disconnected right
they come for you then they come for a
little bit more and a little bit more
and a little bit more and it takes some
time to do that they don't come for
everything all at once one of the other
things going on right now in canada is
bill c-10 this is about regulating the
internet making it so that all of these
independent people these independent
actual journalists uh who are on youtube
who are on rumble who are on some of
these other sites so that they're gonna
have to register with the government so
the government will be able to decide
who can transmit what and the government
will be able to control speech more so
this is huge trouble if you were say
someone like i mentioned earlier gad sad
or jordan peterson you're someone who is
outspoken against the government uh in
canada this is a huge problem places
like rebel news places like the
post-millennial people who are actually
doing journalism um but uh
trudeau's saying that bill c-10 has
nothing to do with uh stopping free
speech it's about it's about making
music more accept accessible to people
yeah yeah why is this government using
c10 to crack down on the free speech
rights of everyday canadians on the
internet
mr speaker allowing it to be absolutely
clear this is not about restricting
content but about making canadian music
more discoverable and available to the
general public freedom of speech is
explicitly protected under the act and
in our charter of rights and freedoms
incredible i mean it's just like these
people that just lie for a living that
everything about them yes what justin
trudeau is mostly concerned about is
people getting access to more music
that's the main thing that he's
interested in as he's taking away the
guns as he's locking people down as he's
making sure people can't leave the
country his main driving thing with this
bill c10 this really is just about music
this has nothing to do with silencing
dissent this has nothing to do with
stopping what he would call
misinformation etc etc uh well we have a
little bit of info on uh c10 this is
from minister of environment and climate
change stephen gilbeau he says the bill
seeks to amend the broadcasting act to
account for the increased prominence of
internet video and digital media by
adding undertakings that conduct
broadcasting over the internet to the
regulatory scope of the canadian radio
television and telecommunications
commission so in essence if you are just
a youtuber if you are a small
independent
news outlet you'll have to register with
these people and they will then be able
to control what you say but that's not
really what it's about according to
justin trudeau it's really about music i
just want everybody to hear the uh who
are the kids listening to now
drake they just want he just wants drake
to get out there to the canadians okay
that's what he wants thank you michael
for that drake he's popular these days
still they like the drake okay um but
this is what justin trudeau is he is a
deeply dishonest basically soulless
soulless nothing he's not he's not
defending canada he's not defending the
people of canada he's just absolutely
awful so i've mentioned jordan peterson
a couple times here here's jordan
peterson uh justin trudeau how can
discourse
in a great democracy have become so
polarized
that jordan peterson and the prime
minister look at exactly the same set of
events and come to opposite conclusions
about them well he's lying
and i'm not
so that's a big part of the
that's a big part of the issue i don't
believe
that he ever says a word that's true
from what i've been able to observe it's
all stage acting he's crafted a persona
he has a particular instrumental
goal in mind and everything is
subordinated to serve that
ain't it the truth ain't the truth and
don't we have way
too many people in our political
establishment our media establishment
that are doing the exact same thing they
are never telling you the truth they are
never even trying to find the truth
they're not even going directionally
towards the truth they are endlessly
doing everything for
political goals so what is this what is
this really about now think about it
there's a horrific horrific shooting in
uvalde texas last week okay
19 kids killed some teachers i mean the
story is still unfolding it sounds like
there were massive failures at every
level in terms of security and the
administration at the school and all of
that stuff we'll find out more about
that what does justin trudeau do he uses
that tragedy as an excuse to take more
political power which by the way is
happening right here in the united
states we'll get to that in just a
second um
and that's what i was referencing
earlier they don't do it all at once
it's too obvious if they come for your
rights all at once so they push and they
push and they wait and they see how far
they can push you etc etc we've played
this clip many times but i think it's
just apropos of everything we're talking
about one more time here's jordan
peterson this is on joe rogan a couple
months back i just don't understand how
it gets to the point where things get to
terrible places one tiny step at a time
you know if i encroach if i encroach on
you and i'm sophisticated about it i'm
going to encroach two millimeters i'm
going to encroach right to the point
where you stop start to protest then i'm
going to stop then i'm going to wait
then you're going to calm down then i'm
going to encroach again right to the
point where you protest then i'm going
to stop then i'm going to wait and i'm
just going to do that forever and before
you know it you're going to be back
three miles from where you started and
you'll have done it one step at a time
and then you'll go oh how'd i get here
and the answer was well
i pushed you a little farther than you
should have gone and you agreed and so
then i pushed you a little farther than
you should have gone again and you
agreed
you see what we're laying out here guys
i think we're making a case right so
what has justin trudeau done in canada
over the last couple years well
lockdowns vaccinations forcing people
out of work all that stuff so they
pushed a certain degree which we all got
pushed to that degree in the west right
then he goes okay now protesting will be
illegal right we're going to stop these
truckers these people who are only
protesting for their right to speak
freely their right to stand up against
their government their right to live as
they see fit we're going to make that
illegal too right because that's exactly
what he did and then what was it after
that oh we're going to freeze their bank
account so it's this move you keep
pushing you keep pushing and you wait a
little bit and you push and you push a
little bit more and after frozen bank
accounts what is it now well now we're
going to come for their guns
so you don't do it all at once this is
how governments work well i can't say
this how governments work this is how
bad authoritarian governments work this
isn't how western governments are
supposed to work but this apparently is
how the canadian government works and uh
if you're in canada and you're watching
this you got you got to think about what
to do you got to think about what to do
i'm telling you i'm meeting a lot of
canadians here in florida these days who
are trying to get the hell out and and
it makes sense where if this is the
direction that canada is going in what
will canada look like uh in five years
but you know what
it ain't just canada it ain't just
canada it's happening right here in the
united states that's what we're going to
cover next uh before i get to that real
quick guys i want to talk to you about
real estate agents i trust you know
buying or selling a home is already one
of the most stressful things you can do
and it can be 10 times worse if you're
not working with the right agent
generally speaking our homes are our
biggest investment that's a lot of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
founded by my good buddy glenn beck we
work with only the best agents in every
market we do our homework talking to
every agent before inviting them to join
our network and here's a big one we only
work with full-time professionals no
part-time or inexperienced agents our
team makes the intro and then follows
you through the buying or selling
process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents we work with have a
long track record and are the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
the process is simple just go to real
estate agents itrust.com today and
provide them with some basic info their
team will contact you to make an intro
to their preferred agent in your town
including many towns in florida and now
back to me all right so if you see
what's going on in canada and you're in
canada i know you're freaking out and i
hope you're thinking about your life and
your family seriously and and what are
you going to do as the tyrannical
government encroaches on you takes away
your guns says to you you cannot defend
yourself we can lock you down whenever
you want we can freeze your bank
accounts etc etc but we have a version
of that happening in the united states
because the government never lets a
crisis go to waste so we have this
horrific again
it's an indescribably horrific event
that happened that transcends politics
that happened in uvalde last week okay
but everyone has made it about politics
and what is everything about right now
it's about taking away the guns we have
to make sure more people can't get guns
we have to take away guns from certain
people etc etc uh here's joe biden very
confused on uh high caliber weapons low
caliber weapons nine millimeters
etcetera etcetera
and they showed me a uh
x-ray
he said a 22-caliber bullet
will lie in a lung
and we can probably get it out you may
be able to save the life
a nine millimeter bullet
so the idea of these
high caliber
weapons
is that
there's simply no rational basis for it
in terms of
about
the constitution the second amendment
was never absolute
okay first off let's do the last line
there i addressed it on friday that is
absolutely a lie the second amendment is
absolute and yes when the second
amendment was codified in the bill of
rights
the average person was allowed to have a
cannon there was nothing that said that
they couldn't okay
the idea was that you could have a
well-formed militia that could stop
government tyranny stop government
overreach okay that's just so that's
just a lie and he just keeps saying it
and nobody stops him in the media okay
the media is not too good either i know
you all get that the other part of what
he said in a very mangled confused sort
of way there was a real escalation in
terms of what the democrats are doing on
guns because in essence he's supporting
a ban on nine millimeter handguns first
off these are low caliber weapons this
is not a high capacity weapon these are
handguns
now it's interesting because justin
trudeau in the clip we just showed you
earlier was talking about banning
handguns and now you hear have joe biden
in essence saying the same thing now he
may be confused i suppose that every
time he says something you don't know if
he means it or they wrote it or he's
just going off the cuff or if he
literally has no idea what he's saying
but he is suggesting a ban on nine
millimeter handguns these are not ar-15s
etc etc so that's where joe biden is at
with this whole thing uh here's press
secretary jean pierre
talking about the age limit related to
buying assault weapons the average age
of suspects at school mass shootings is
18.
would the president support raising
the age at which someone can buy a gun
to 21. so the president was very clear
about this just recently when he said
that uh
that in his remarks just on tuesday that
it doesn't make sense for an 18 year old
to legally buy an assault weapon and so
he made very clear on tuesday when he
after he landed from asia and had to
deal with such a devastating uh news
that happened in texas okay so first off
as i just noted to my guys as we were
playing the clip it's just so obvious
that all of the people basically except
for peter ducey at fox that are sitting
in the white house press conferences
they're just plants they're government
plants who ask the exact questions that
they want that the administration wants
them to ask now as far as this 18 to 21
issue and the age of the people who are
mass shooters because we obviously have
a mass mental health problem in this
country and we also have an issue with
young men in a society that wants to
throw these people away especially if
they're young straight white men is
there some discussion to have related to
the age limit when buying a gun there
probably is there probably is does it
make sense that you can't drink at 18
but you can go to war right
the voting age all of these
inconsistencies related to all of these
things so is there some discussion
perhaps that 18
related to your full uh you know your
brain health and all of these things
your brain maturity uh is there some
discussion to have about that of course
there is now the problem is that because
the left never stops you can see them
making the move right now now we're
gonna stop certain set of people from
getting getting guns and we're gonna
start talking about that handguns will
be moved and we're gonna ban all assault
weapons even though we're not exactly
sure what those are all of these things
this is where i am so sympathetic to
people on the right
who years ago maybe i thought were more
extreme in a certain degree that if you
give the left an inch on anything if a
crisis happens and then you negotiate in
the midst of that crisis they will just
keep coming and coming and coming show
me one instance where these people ever
stop show me one instance where they
ever say oh enough is enough or maybe we
should think thing things through or
maybe we have to look at ourselves or
maybe our presuppositions with all of
these issues aren't quite right and it's
not just about guns and everything else
well kamala harris she wants to ban
assault weapons and you know she
obviously she doesn't know what anything
is but she certainly doesn't know what
assault weapons are we've got some info
from cnn
vice president kamala harris called for
an assault weapons ban on saturday
saying that in the wake of two
back-to-back mass shootings such arms
are a weapon of war with no place in a
civil society on the issue of gun
violence i will say as i've said
countless times we are not sitting
around waiting to figure out what the
solution looks like you know we're not
looking for a vaccine harris told
reporters in buffalo new york after
attending the funeral for a victim of a
mass shooting there earlier this month
we know what works on this it includes
let's have an assault weapons man
you know what an assault weapon is you
know what an assault weapon was designed
she continued it was designed for a
specific purpose to kill a lot of human
beings quickly an assault weapon is a
weapon of war with no place no place in
a civil society so what she's saying is
she wants the government to have all of
the ability to kill a lot of people but
people shouldn't have the ability to
defend themselves now we can have again
that honest discussion about the
magazine capacity and all of those
things and who needs what and can we do
background checks a little bit better
and all of those things but this is this
is really just about the move and she
says you know what works
no we don't you know what works well why
do you guys never talk about mental
health again if i had an ar-15 sitting
on this table right now there is zero
chance i would run around and start
murdering people i would not go to a
school or a temple or a church or
anywhere else and start mass shooting
people so it is not about the weapon
specifically can we have some discussion
about who can get access to that weapon
absolutely but it so when you say it's
we know what works that's they're so
good at that we know what works it's
obvious it's obvious what works
not exactly guns have been in this
country for 250 years and school
shootings have magically basically
started in the last 20 years or so so is
something else going on is something
about political polarization going on is
something about mental health going on
is something about the internet going on
it's something about self-worth and
meaning going on i suspect it has
something to do with that and perhaps it
also has a little something to do
with the people who are supposedly in
charge who are scaring the hell out of
everybody all the time here's new york
senator chuck schumer
no amount of bloodshed seems to be
enough
for mega republicans
this nation is
enraged
as well as being exhausted
it's been through this over and over and
over again over the last two two decades
people are sick of mourning again and
again while listening to the same string
of hollow words from the maga
republicans
that never lead to action
man the theme of this show should be i'm
going to just show you a bunch of really
horrible people i mean chuck schumer
chuck schumer used to be uh 20 years ago
was a kind of sane centrist democrat he
was a new york liberal yes but he was
not an insane ideologue and that is
exactly what he has become and and that
seemingly is what happens to all of
these leftists that quote no amount of
bloodshed seems to be enough for mega
republicans what a vile
disgusting dishonest thing to say do you
think any maga republican do you think
any republican any conservative is happy
about the bloodshed in uvalde what they
see is a different problem and a
different solution than you see chuck
schumer but we could just as easily say
the same thing about you we could just
as easily say see look at the horrible
ideas that you ridiculous
leftists have imported into society that
have so destroyed so much and that you
don't leave people defensible that they
can't defend themselves and people are
confused about their gender and their
sexuality and racism and all the fears
the winter of death that's coming that
you people have ushered in this
collective mental state that everyone is
in does that get us anywhere but yes the
mag of republicans want bloodshed
there's never enough bloodshed
man these people are just absolutely
horrible and speaking of horrible people
joy reid is one of the hosts over at the
televised mental institution known as
msnbc and really listen to what she says
here really listen to what she says and
let's see if you can get to my
conclusion i'm pretty sure you can good
evening everyone we begin the readout
tonight with republicans just tying
themselves into pretzels to point the
figure in every single thing but the
problem the gun
in the wake of the murders of 19 4th
graders and two of their teachers in
uvalde texas
from mental health to arming teachers to
more armed law enforcement in schools
every single thing
as far as we know there was no mental
health issue with the individual who
stole the futures of 19 children in
uvalde texas
that line right there you got it already
i know you got it you guys are good if
you're watching the show that line might
be the stupidest thing that has ever
been said
on msnbc and that is an incredible
statement to make and i think it might
be
the idea
that a young 18 year old kid
walks into a school murders
4th graders and some teachers
there's no evidence he has a mental
health problem it's about the gun
that is so absolutely
effing bananas that that someone at ms
she should have been fired on the spot
if msnbc was a news organization and
they're not it's a clown show ridiculous
progressive propaganda network
she should have been fired immediately
that statement is so
insane
it's so reverse and then she said well
all they want to talk they don't want to
talk about the gun the gun's obviously
the problem they only want to talk about
mental health and this had nothing to do
with mental health
everyone in this watching this you all
know 18 year olds you all know 17 year
olds and 19 year olds okay
none of them that you know
most likely would do anything like this
this kid had a massive mental problem
it's off the charts what his mental
problem was okay we may never know
exactly what it was but why doesn't she
want to talk about mental health why
doesn't she want to talk about security
at the school why doesn't she want to
talk all all about the cultural nonsense
that is unearthing this because they're
the ones peddling all of this so on one
hand you've got chuck schumer saying ah
you see the republicans and those mega
conservatives and blah blah there's
never enough blood for them and in
essence they're excusing the shooter he
obviously had no
capacity over in his own mind there was
just a gun there so he decided to kill a
lot of people
complete insanity complete insanity and
they're doing exactly what they accuse
all of us
of doing but you know what guys
what do i always try to do here you know
i always try to give hope and there is
always hope there really is and and we
just have to keep focusing on that we
have to push back and tell the truth
even when it is difficult to do so uh so
there was a big nra convention over the
last couple days uh and here is senator
ted cruz making sense many of these same
people make their accusations from
behind great bulwarks of safety
from gated communities equipped with
private security or at the very least
from safe and expensive neighborhoods
protected by high home prices
and low crime rates
such people can afford an indulgent
ideology
that ignores reality
as is so often the case
those furthest from the halls of power
are the most dependent on the ability to
defend themselves
in an age where elites embrace defunding
the police
when homelessness runs rampant
when gangs dominate entire communities
and when radical district attorneys
refuse to prosecute violent crime in
cities across america
rarely
has the second amendment been more
necessary to secure the rights
of our fellow citizens
[Music]
[Applause]
everything he said there was true
everything he said there was true any of
these politicians do you think chuck
schumer has armed security around him of
course he does do you think mark
zuckerberg has armed security at his
house of course he does do you think
wherever their children go to school any
of these people literally any of these
people where their children go to school
where they live have better policing or
or their own private security or all of
those things yes that's what they have
for themselves
they want to take away your ability to
defend yourself this is not a radical
thing that i'm saying it is an obvious
thing understand it and know it and then
there's the broader conversation here
which is about what political priorities
are in dc they don't really do anything
right they seemingly always just want
more of us more from us whether it's our
money or it's our attention or it's our
rights
so donald trump also spoke at the nra
convention
and here he made a good point about what
we do with funding seemingly we can give
money to everybody else but we can't
take care of ourselves this is not a
matter of money this is a matter of will
if the united states has 40 billion
dollars to send to ukraine we should be
able to do whatever it takes to keep our
children
safe at home
at a radical position right basically
every senator except for i think 13
republicans voted just in the last two
weeks to give another 40 billion dollars
to ukraine we have no idea where that
money's going we're not getting receipts
on any of that if you want more on that
i did a short interview with senator
rand paul who did vote against it which
is up on youtube and rumble and
everywhere else
but we can find money to give weapons
bombs guns etc we can give that using
our own money that we don't have that
we're borrowing from china we can send
that over to ukraine but why can't we
how come nobody proposed all right how
about i don't know four billion dollars
to defend our schools how about that how
about that how about we really look at
what is the what are the weaknesses of
these schools i'm not even saying this
is fully the answer because i really
think this is far more of a mental
health issue but what about really
assessing what every
public school and private school and
charter school and everything should be
doing right now and i suspect the public
ones certainly the wealthy public
that i suspect that the private ones and
the charter ones especially the wealthy
ones are doing it right now really
assessing hey what are our security
guards doing what are our
points of entry what are the weak spots
here and all of those things but we're
not really going to do that
right i don't think randy weingarten is
going to be pushing for that right she's
head of the the teachers union i don't
think she's really going to be pushing
for that she'll be pushing for getting
rid of guns leaving the schools more
exposed and the simple truth that we all
know
we all know is that if you take away
guns first off there are probably 400
million guns something like that what's
the number i think it's around 350
million if i'm not mistaken guns in the
united states right now and it's an
estimate because they don't fully know
but there basically are as many guns as
people something like that in the united
states right now um if you say okay
we're going to take away 100 million
guns and we're going to make it harder
for 18 year olds to get guns etc etc
what will happen is that bad guys will
be the only people to have guns there
are
393.3 million guns in the united states
right now there are an awful lot of new
gun owners in the united states over the
last two years ourselves included
because we realized especially living in
los angeles we could not depend on the
defunded police and the ridiculous
district attorneys to defend us as riots
literally went by our house so the point
is that you could take away guns from
people and who will give up guns who who
will do a buyback now they always say a
buyback on guns except a buyback would
be if the same person who sold you the
gun bought it back this is a buyback
when the government is going to give you
money for it doesn't really buy back
that i don't think that's the technical
term on that one but the simple truth is
the more that you say okay we'll get
some of these guns off the streets good
people will give up their guns good guys
who have decided to defend themselves
will give up their guns the bad guys
will still have the guns this is a point
there's a clip going around uh twitter
right now that's going viral that joe
rogan has been making for quite some
time
i wrote this thing once that said this
country has a mental health problem
disguised as a gun problem
and that's what it is and i don't think
it's wise to take the guns away from the
people and leave all the power of the
government we see how they are even with
an armed populace they still have
a tendency towards totalitarianism
and there's a natural inclination when
you're a person in power to try to hold
more power and acquire more power and
it's never there's never an inclination
to give more power back to the people to
give more freedoms back to people
freedom's laws are rarely regained
how do you stop that no one knows how to
stop that what what's the answer is the
answer take everyone's guns well they're
not going to give their guns up so it's
going to you're going to have only
criminals are going to have guns
an interesting line there no one knows
how to stop that i i think there are
some ways to stop that actually we're
gonna do a cold close with thomas soul
from an interview i did with him a
couple years ago where he talks about
how you can stop it and that you can
actually stop the ever encroaching
government you just kind of have to have
the will to do it but who in this if
you've been watching this show from the
beginning it's like who has made sense
in these clips that we've showed you was
it was it joe rogan right there saying
we have a mental health problem not a
gun problem was it jordan peterson
talking about the inch by inch that
they'll come get you uh was it ted cruz
saying that in essence
this is never going to stop that the
elites have it one way and that they
want you to live another way that we
know they don't live as they defund the
police and make sure that your
neighborhoods are more dangerous is it
those people that are making sense or or
did you watch this show and do you think
that justin trudeau made sense as he
made sure as he pushes this through
canadian parliament that the average
person in canada will not be able to buy
or sell a gun and defend their family
uh or was it uh was it joy reid who you
thought made sense there who said that
the shooter did not have a mental health
problem or was it chuck schumer who you
thought made sense there who said that
the maga republicans never get enough
blood that they have this endless
bloodlust
it's it's so obvious if you if you just
calmly try to think about these things
what is going on here and uh i think
i think
that if we calmly explain ourselves if
we fight earnestly and honestly that
that
like most of the issues of the day uh we
will win but they will not stop they
will not stop it is as simple as that uh
so i thought we'd do a cold close today
no we're gonna include it in this
segment you want all right we're gonna i
like this we're changing it on the fly
so you know what we're gonna switch it
up uh here is thomas soule uh this is
the interview that i did with thomas
soul in 2018. i asked him about this
very point that joe rogan just
referenced there where is it ever too
late to take back government power uh
and thomas sol well thomas ladies and
gentlemen and in a area where the
government has taken on a bigger role
than it's supposed to i think one of the
things you hear all the time is it's
sort of too late i think a lot of people
think it's too late to take back that
government power no you
heavens uh
during the reagan administration that
was the only time
i know of
when the federal register grew smaller
where they compiled all the laws that
have been passed in a given time
so it can be done it's not it's not it's
not uh it's not it's not
easy
but it can be done someone wants there
was some
issues that reagan was discussing and
someone said you know it it's
complicated he said it's not complicated
it's just not easy to do
really this would be about just sort of
electing more libertarian-minded
politicians then i mean is that really
the only way we can change things do you
think no i think the main thing people
have to know what the facts are
themselves
uh if if everyone knew what all the
facts were i think you'd have an
entirely different set of people elected
oh i love that line right it's like if
we could just inform people enough they
wouldn't be falling for this nonsense
right the the the empty shell of a human
being justin trudeau sounding like a
nice guy with his nice suit and his nice
hair and his nice socks saying things
that sounds right if you had an informed
electorate people wouldn't fall for it
right if you perhaps this is exactly why
democrats here want everyone to go to
public schools and they're so afraid of
private schools and charter schools and
homeschooling because they need people
to be stupid maybe it's really that
simple they need a seriously misinformed
confused
dumb
dumb
uh
group of people who have an a historical
take on who built this country and what
it's all about so that they can
continuously and continuously attain
power but underneath everything soul is
talking about there and man if you have
not seen that interview i hope that
you'll go watch it after let's make sure
we link to that original interview uh in
this video
um
and you can hear it actually in my voice
you know i never get nervous i i can
speak in front of 10 000 people i do
whatever shows i do i never get nervous
about any of this stuff it's like this
is what i'm supposed to be doing so i
don't feel nerves related to any of this
then when i do stand up or anything else
i never feel nervous that's the only
time i think in my professional life
i've ever really been nervous you can
hear it in my voice there's almost like
a frog in my throat as i was talking
because i was just like man this is such
a living legend um but the point there
is you just have to have the will to do
it
okay so we can have an informed populist
that'll that'll be good enough of us
will know what reality is we'll know
what our rights are
we'll understand what what these people
are
but then you have to you have to have
the will it's complicated to do things
okay but so what we're going to do
things
we're going to make things happen we're
not going to let you take our rights and
you need to find enough people who are
willing to do that and occasionally you
are lucky enough to find a politician
who will do
just that and i guess those are the
people that we need more of right now uh
we do have an interesting cold close for
you now that we we've mixed that thing
up couple comments from
reubenreport.locals.com
uh amy says i cannot wait to see
governor desantis this thursday that's
right speaking of those type of leaders
a couple tickets left at daverubin.com
events and by the way we are doing a
reuben report community meetup
for members of the locals community i
think there's gonna be about 100 people
there that's last i heard breakfast is
on me for everyone eat till your heart
is full with love and food your belly
with food and your heart with love
something like that jeb says kind of
hard to blame trudeau when canadians
elected him and then re-elected him he
has never been subtle about his
philosophy or intentions yeah that's
interesting i mean look the liberal
party there and trudeau i think he got
around 33 of the vote
uh last time so it's just that you know
they have several parties and things get
broken up um but you get what you vote
for at the end of the day and it's a
damn shame a year ago that they did not
look themselves in the mirror and say
this guy is not doing the right thing
it's uh
it's on canadians to figure out what
you're going to do about this if this is
the country that you want to fight for
is this the country you want to live in
i mean really think about it there are
unvaccinated people in canada who cannot
leave the country right now is there any
other western nation that is doing that
what is it really about
is it about that canada wants to make
sure that they're not exporting sick
people into other western nations or is
it that they are breaking all of the
freedom-loving people in their own
nation and for what purposes what seems
more real what seems
more honest to you
patrick says jordan looks so
distinguished if morgan freeman passes
away they can cast jordan to play god
yeah jordan when he's like peaked jordan
when the although in that video that we
showed you earlier uh he didn't have
like full beer jordan but when he's in
full beard salt and pepper jordan it's
like man
that's jordan i'm seeing jordan a little
later today actually i think he's in the
area right now he's in the area uh
reminder the big show at desantis is on
thursday i'm very excited it's going to
be a big one uh and join us if you want
to play along during the show for the
live chat at reubenreport.locals.com
and uh here's very confused joseph r
biden
that has caused carnage on our streets
150 million people have been killed
since 2007 when bernie voted to exempt
the gun manufacturers from liability
more than all the wars
including vietnam from that point